this month did you know it's national
black business month yeah it is and
we're introducing you to one pioneering
business leader for a change in the game
series and she has certainly done that
it focuses on extraordinary women who
are making a difference now and for
future generations april showers she's
the founder and ceo of afro unicorn she
created the cartoon character in 2019 to
remind women and kids of color how
unique divine and how magical they truly
are now there are t-shirts there are
backpacks and even some stuffed animals
earlier this year april launched afro
unicorn party supplies in walmart star
walmart stores she's trying to say she
is the first black woman to own a
licensed character sold by a major
retailer drop the microphone on that
take a look as april sees her brand in
the stores for the very first time
i'm nervous i'm excited i'm excited and
nervous i'm nervous and excited excited
and nervous but here we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
now
look
i didn't see the nerves i just saw all
the excitement april showers welcome
welcome welcome welcome thank you for
having me so i'm i'm trying to picture
this are you just walking through stores
and you thought i don't see a black
unicorn so let me do one how did this
happen
no i was being referred to as a unicorn
over and over again i'm an entrepreneur
a friend a friend so you're an
entrepreneur i have a insurance agency
i'm a licensed real estate broker i'm a
single mom of two amazing honorable
student boys hey honor roll student boys
okay go ahead and someone kept referring
to me as a unicorn and i'm like why do
you keep calling me a unicorn he said
well because you have your businesses
you're raising your boys i'm a woman
that's what we do no april you're doing
an extraordinary level you are indeed
the unicorn so they're saying you're
exceptional but did you know what a
unicorn was i had no clue i googled them
i saw that they were mythical they were
unique and i'm like okay i'm magical on
black girl magic i'm definitely unique i
started to use that emoji over and over
again whenever i would text copy always
that emoji and then one day like a pound
of bricks it hit me
why is it that something that's supposed
to represent who i am and who
like my characteristics why is it only
white like who determined that unicorns
were only supposed to be white so it no
longer resonated with me uh-huh so i
went to go find one that looked like me
i couldn't find anything and so instead
of complaining about it i wanted to be
the change that i wanted to see that's
why i created africa and then the brand
really took off because of a viral video
with a little girl cassidy i think her
name is let's roll a little bit of that
video and then we'll talk about it
i love your hair thank you
it's an app though
i remember that video she's got the
shirt on there how did that moment uh
lead to you getting into walmart that
other moment we saw at the top of the of
the piece well thanks to oprah daley oh
yeah posted that viral video cassidy was
just doing what she does she loves
afternoon she was taking photos someone
walked by her so it was a photo shoot
for your photo shoot from our brand
someone walked by and said i love your
hair she's confident thank you it's an
afro that video went viral you were
oprah daily shared it and then from
there walmart emailed me and said after
unicorn x walmart collaboration have you
ever considered party supplies wow and
that doesn't happen it's amazing it is
amazing and when you look at the
placement why because this is a big deal
where you're placed in the store yes
we're not right next to disney
princesses yes right next to all of the
lol
we're right front and center we hang
with all the knicks marvel we're right
there it's incredible it's incredible
it's a very short amount of time so what
are the lessons there are people looking
at the tv right now and they have ideas
they want to go places what what do you
tell people who want to go from idea to
something like this in their lives
consistency
a lot of people give up too quick and
they don't show up every day you have to
show up every day you have to be very
very consistent
and you have to believe in what you're
starting yeah i see it through i can
tell by those shoes you show up every
day you call it you call it like hello
kitty you compared to hello kitty
african corn is the modern day hello
kitty hello kitty we're everywhere we're
on everything we'll be
we're all we're in retail now we're in
walmart we're going to be in target in
the fall you must be so proud april
honestly because you got into walmart
this year right may of 2022 may 2023 of
2022. so when you look at all you've
accomplished you must feel really really
proud of what you've done i do i feel
really empowered
i feel very empowered
i just feel like we are creating that
blueprint moving forward yeah a little
birdie told me there's going to be
another major store coming up soon where
you're going to be your products can be
available i don't think you're quite
ready to make that announcement yet
because it's coming it's coming this is
growing april showers do you bring
mayflowers always i know how many people
have said that to you all my life but
you know growing up with the kids they
they call me april o'neil from the
turtles i'm like you're not even that
creative like there's a whole april
shower thing here
congratulations cheering you on continue
success thank you yes